[Music]
[Applause]
i saw you jumping into the [ __ ] bed
you're the one that jumped in the van oh
he's right he freaking killed four
among us is a multiplayer game where
you're on the spaceship there will be
crew members and there will be
impostors the job for the crew members
is to complete tasks
and the job for an imposter is to kill
all the crew members the crew members
can
decide to have a meeting where they try
to figure out who the imposter is and
vote them off the ship
it's a game about lying deceit and
epicness
enjoy all right welcome welcome we don't
lie here this is the
non-lying edition wait am i mutant okay
it's weird playing with people i've
literally never talked to
because it's like now they're gonna lie
to me and [ __ ] i don't like this
all right all right who did it just
admit it oh my god
just admit it body and i think it's like
in the locker room maybe on the south
side me and pj you just walked right
past it
which side the left all right uh kind of
like the middle center
oh storage yeah yeah storage okay i just
ran through there and i saw
cops in comms nobody else was there
though
pdf where were you huh yeah i was with
ken uh so i can't say ken is that true
one of the two yeah all right all right
i was like swiping a card just before
yeah
like failing over there corpse scarfs
what we did
i'm with lizzie and comms
why did you vote lizzy i skipped i
skipped oh okay
if you don't skip then somebody can vote
oh you're right you're right
all right i thought skipped if he didn't
i thought that's what you did
i have not been paying attention to this
game
oh my god oh no i just found a dead body
in the south
oh my god i ran past uh yeah
you sounded really shocked about that oh
my god i can't believe that's how i
always sound man
all right grande what were
you vote why did i buy it yeah because i
don't trust anybody
just specifically all right all right
all right
i need i need to check the people all
right corpse
don't come near me
because you're so innocent no one ever
wants to be
there's no difference between you being
innocent or guilty because you sound
like you're going to start laughing
all the time i've felt bad so many times
when we've thrown them in space that i'm
just like man
that's the thing good luck everyone
there's no luck if no one lies
oh there's two imposters all right dylan
you better do a good job here i think
lizzy is too good at this game she's
going to figure out if
it's me i'm tasking oop did a task
sorry guys i had to call an emergency
meeting because i'd like to ask
cyan why you were stood at the trash
disposal
and you weren't disposing of the trash
yeah i didn't see it either actually it
took a long time
yeah that's true because i didn't know
you guys couldn't do it that's literally
the only one
you can actually see i enjoy killing
randy it's one of
the biggest i couldn't use the trash and
dave's like you couldn't be incompetent
enough to do that
oh yeah that'd be really sad actually
this is hilarious come on
just do the leave see i can't be around
lizzy
i mean she literally kicked out granted
that was all her let's wait for the task
to move and then we'll move
there we go look at great dave was
checking it too
oh no
come back
[Applause]
come on explain yourselves a little bit
better we got time literally i saw him
kill corpse and then he went into the
vent thinking i wouldn't see him
where did this happen yeah the cockpit
cockpit carpet
pewdie if ken tried to jump in an event
and get away then why did ken report the
body
you could do that as a tactic you can
definitely do that if he already jumped
in the vent and ran away oh yeah
because he's trying to get me now yeah
he doesn't yeah it doesn't make sense
why didn't judy report the body then
because i didn't have time to click on
it
so we jumped in the vent and jumped out
and then reported the body
listen i don't make the rules
felix yeah i i would skip because i'm
not really sure
sorry granted i'm so sorry
i just found dylan standing right over
my body wait wait
do you know how to report bodies
yes you were standing on a body you
didn't
i was asking if he was okay
dylan's new to the games i can totally
see that yeah maybe
lizzy what have you been doing i've been
doing my tasks basically
um the o2 went off um i did
the leaves putting the leaves through
the filter
um in the o2 room dylan's getting away
with it
he's getting away with that he's gone
and dylan was the last person i saw in
that area
i can't wait to hear the reaction
[Music]
have you been playing this because that
this was my first game and i honestly
don't know what i'm doing
i honestly have no idea
i don't have the game i don't believe
oh it's midday this should be fun what
are we doing dave
oh let's see should i report they
well corpse let us know what happened
okay
so i'm confused wait hold on the body's
in the
most southern room i just walked past
two people and i was like oh wait it
couldn't be them because those were two
people but then i realized they could
both be killers and i forgot who they
were
no you didn't notice who it was i can't
believe he saw us
and he [ __ ] forgot who he saw that's
so [ __ ] funny
all right what's the imagination okay i
literally saw dave kill someone like
that
i saw him too it's totally i was clearly
about to record it
dave i was just with
lizzy doing the the hand reactor thing
and then i looked down and she's dead i
saw dave run in the room there could be
someone else in the room below me which
remy did you report uh lizzie's body no
i saw dylan's body and then i ran to the
emergency button because i had it
okay so no one saw lizzie's body because
it's right in front of me
so you you were by the body and you
didn't report the body you went to the
button instead
yeah that's yeah yeah it's i think
i think it's roomy don't you hear that
dave's voice is all weird yeah but you
always call someone out
i'm thinking dave i don't always call
someone else when did i do that last
time i think it's felix
okay how about this next time through me
and then we'll see we lose
yeah i literally saw him so now you know
not me i should have thrown dave out of
the bus
i should have thrown dave under the bus
i gotta kill joel
real freaking fast you're [ __ ] dead
[ __ ] oh that's so smart today to report
up here because no one's going to run up
here now
all right who's left
thank you dave
you guys didn't listen to me it was so
obvious
i'm so sorry it's totally worth it
[Laughter]
i'm so irritated because i got it all
right no more lying guys i don't like it
the editor's honor editors are
listening listen listen look look
look i'm safe you understand does that
mean lizzy's safe though that's a real
question
i found a body
oh my god what the [ __ ] i found pj in
like the engine room
this is really bad
yeah the reactor i don't believe why why
don't you believe him there's nothing i
really believe
it's just when he says really bad
guys this is a disaster that is true
actually
there's nothing i can add to the story i
just walked in there i haven't seen
anything or anything like that uh
dave what do you mean dave i literally
sit nice seeing you do a single task
i've been down the bottom of the ship
and i went up round navigation and i
came round to the left
dudes was in uh the trash he was showing
me the trash and then you came from the
left i think
i'm pretty suspicious of dave i'm
casting my vote i don't like her
you're just throwing votes out i'm
voting on you lizzy my gosh
no no liar don't pretend to be shocked
get the hell out of this [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can
throw the action
oh god oh my god [ __ ] why did you vote
for dave like that
no
i have a plan he can't just throw him i
love your move
you killed two of us at the same time in
that one room that was really nice
judy i was with you though literally the
whole yeah but i didn't see you do any
tasks
i just threw my ass but i also wasn't
doing any murdering
that should have been a clue but you
should have said that all right
no more lying all right yeah no more
lying no no more just
there's no reason editor's honor
i i was thrown off by the fact that she
um just voted for dave out of nowhere
even though oh all right that's my
revenge isn't it
okay um yeah the feud's dead and
we just what um
[Laughter]
they killed him i promise i'm not the
only editor's honor
the game oh maybe his internet camera
yeah it sounded like his internet
yeah if he wasn't he was the imposter
and he didn't want to lie
yeah that's a sneaker that's a oh my god
i really don't know anything here i
literally haven't seen anyone else
felix killed himself anymore
uh i i wouldn't win he did it and and
maybe
lizzy in there yeah i can't remember who
i was with i'll get him next time boys
two imposters remain this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm gonna do my task
i'm just out here doing oh you got ppcam
now
i hope you enjoy it i'm just out here
doing tasks oh
[ __ ] they they've got us god that was so
good
i'm so glad this is good at this game
this is the first this is the first time
i've ever won thank you lizzy
oh you're welcome ah feels good
i gotta wait for someone to do a test
because no one's literally done attack
i see a dead body in the cockpit i
didn't see anyone going in or uh
dave was kind of running by me and he
didn't do anything so don't think it's
dave
i just saw lizzy but i don't think it
was you i was doing the
leaves and then i ran off to yeah yeah i
saw that yeah
i wondered why you ran off to the right
which is kind of weird but you found a
dead body
i found the body yeah well you could
also self-report feel like
what tax tasks have you done uh
literally the one that was next to lizzy
i don't know what it's called
murder what do you do what did you have
to do what do you do with that task the
laser one
laser yeah is there a laser one there
yeah there's even by laser
like the you drag the thing up down left
right
listen i don't know how to explain all
the tasks i just saw a body
i reported it [ __ ]
i think i think i think i'm going to
vote for felix i think your task sounds
really weird yeah it does
i'm going to wear a spaceship i'm doing
laser stuff
what the [ __ ] even if he's not the
impulse no no
oh you just want to get bullets i hate
this game
you didn't get kicked out you're fun
i saw a body i think it's dave you've
seen
a lot of bodies uh felix wait where was
it looking pretty
clearly i was right next to you jaden i
saw you and
pj going around where the body was
because i saw it just at the end they've
literally walked over it
i don't think that's possible wait where
was it it's in the bottom left
literally where jane was i don't know
what if he's just dudes and he's running
around murdering people and
self-reporting it immediately
i only i didn't report that no no
very possible let's kill lizzy
[Music]
the laser
i was thinking that that's funny he
looks his move is throw whoever the
other imposters under the bus
all right take a note no assistance dave
gets overly aggressive and
starts accusing everyone that's his tail
dave's always getting blamed i don't
think petey is ready he's
trying to end he's trying to enter the
vent
pj no oh he's locked in
all right i found ken's dead body
by the trash machine yeah i can vouch
did you see me who was just with us in
comms was it ken
i i don't remember i saw you were there
somebody went through the door and i
don't know who it was so that leaves
dylan felix jaden pj
i saw lizzie but i was in the cafeteria
you saw me in the cafeteria
no i saw you i was in the cafeteria but
i wasn't in the cafeteria
yeah but i can you can see through rooms
i'm just saying
what are you what are you talking about
i can see everything so
no we skipped i've been confused for a
while all right
i'm a bad liar well they're not getting
me all right dude i swear i [ __ ] saw
her
you can see through
all right dylan's locked from me what's
happened
i found a body in the most southern room
i just came from the left
with roomies so it's not roomy the door
was
i'm near roomie and i didn't see you
anywhere of course
nothing i'm falling behind him and i
didn't see him corpse was there right
before you came dave
i can't tell who's talking but the door
was locked from the right so it's none
of us on the
on the left who's also on i was on the
right doing white
security at the moment i'm still a
little suspicious of corpse and joel
because i didn't see corpse there but i
didn't see well that kind of makes me
suspicious of
you the bad guess you you i just
yeah dave okay well that leaves jaden
felix pj right i don't know whatever
yeah i saw jaden run into nab
on the camera so felix or pj
pj was alone in med bay with dave and i
could have killed me
and dave was alive in there so that
makes me think it's not pj no no yeah i
was doing medicine
okay that's good for now because i think
it could be roommates oh
it was locked i couldn't physically get
in to kill the body it's like not
possible wait who would have me
i did you [ __ ] [ __ ] uh-oh dave
okay so dave seems really weird now
uh i'll i'll use pd as my alibi now
then we'll kill whoever i saw here oh
okay
uh i guess it's not dave south southern
part
i'm pulling into this thought pattern
that pj and lizzie were really like
aggressive on in the first round i think
especially pj was uncharacteristically
just on the ball
but that's not i'm just no i'm just
getting yeah i wasn't aggressive i
haven't voted for anyone yet i've
skipped every round
the way you guys are talking like right
now everyone else is kind of chill and
you guys are
i feel like i'm always aggressive i'm
always you know about me
i'm pretty sure it's roomy by the way
guys okay now i'm really suspicious of
you lizzie wow
i just i don't know how i don't have
anything to listen what were you doing
my innocence jayden i was in the nuclear
room the reactor room with you i could
have killed you pj ran in
pj was doing a test up there i was stuck
on the really long simon says task in
the reactor room oh god yeah i hate that
one
i'm doing roommate i oh my god no it's
not wow
no no oh
no oh okay we're done nice
yeah pj was definitely had higher energy
than usual i'm sorry
it's so funny when my chat tells me to
shut up because it's like they're
working against each other just be quiet
like all right
it's not fair we really made it easy for
you
all right i'm a crewmate this time oh is
ken is going to kill me now
i'm scared of ken if it's if ken sekeli
is going to kill me right away i need to
find someone
i think lizzy might be a killer [ __ ]
no
all right watch me do a test then
okay okay i think liz is not a kid oh
all right she's my alibi all right what
do we got someone killed ken again
no i thought ken was the killer are you
serious
bottom left of the map
yeah i could have vouched for ken
because he did the task at the bottom as
well
he let the thing out i saw jaden had a
chance to kill me and did i
i think lizzy's safe but i'm not sure
pewter's following me the entire time
i'm terrified i was harassing corpse and
he didn't kill me
dylan what were you doing in med bay
[Music]
i'm trying to figure out which task to
do
[Music]
yeah how the tasks work all right
i called him out just so you know i'm
safe all right okay
300 iq strat all right i just realized
uh corpse was the only one vouching for
dylan last one
just yeah you did you literally said i
really don't think it said i'm just
saying
i want to see corpse do a task after
this meeting
me and joel just saw each other do med
base so we're for sure
it was pretty cute how many are we we're
five okay we should be okay i'm gonna
report soon
all right i think it's safe all right pj
next
pj is the only one that i haven't
cleared i think it's pj
let's go and see oh there it is he did
do a task there didn't he
this is so tough
dead body whoa okay well a lot of us
were
together we were all together person
that wasn't there
it was wait was it joel what it was rumi
ruby wasn't there yeah
were you anywhere near the body at any
point uh not that i saw no i was in the
med bay i did like and then i did like a
bunch of wiring and then the wiring was
like go to the other wiring
did i even tell you where the body was
no you didn't oh
but i didn't see a body that's what i
thought you asked then how did you
no i said were you even near where the
body was yeah and then you were
wiring yourself wiring is the go-to no
come on
i'm not that smart
no i'm sorry john all right meeting
meeting meeting hell
all right all right we're doing this
right so pj then
who is next dj no no no i was with you
guys
okay but there was a while away you went
i feel like i saw pj doing the history
now i didn't know we were trying to what
team up fine
we're clearly hanging out i don't know
either let's do pj this round corpse
next round and we're good
okay wait why is dave leading the who to
vote out
because all three of us were together we
just have the logic there
i thought i i could be completely wrong
but i thought i
saw pj do a task and the bar didn't go
up but i'm not completely sure
oh god no if i'm wrong my bad my bad
but please there we have it guys
yes i think corpse found my body right
and then
p.j was like oh yeah i could have
vouched for him because he was doing
this job like right where i died but
just put it together my memory only
lasts about uh
three rounds and then i forget yeah what
happened in like round one i forget
anyway i've got a head off so it was
really fun playing with you yeah great
playing yeah
yeah it might be a good time to end it
then thanks guys
take care bye-bye thanks for watching
stream that was so fun
floor gang out
children of nine parks
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming too
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big tv
pre-order promotion i mean
we